What kind of relationship do you have
with your father,
your real father?
So often ambivalent,
right?
Because the earth,
there's an element of him that
encouraged you,
hopefully because without the
encouragement of your father,
man,
the world is at dismal place.
It's very difficult to be a courageous
person unless you have your father in
body and spirit behind you.
It's very dear,
demoralizing,
like it really kills people not to have
their mother.
They just don't recover from that,
but and I think people can recover from
a fragmented father relationship,
but it's the next worst thing you know,
because if your father rejects you or
doesn't form a relationship with you,
it says,
if the spirit of civilization has left
you outside the walls as of little
worth,
it's very difficult for people to
recover from that.
So the father should be an encouraging
forest but can be a tyrannical and
crushing for us.
And so that's very.
That's a very difficult thing to get
right?
Partly because
if you're my son,
then I should impose the highest
standards of behavior on you and I
should always be judging what you're
doing.
Why should it be judging it with,
with the aim of making the best in you
come forward,
but,
but getting that balance exactly right
is very difficult and so it's easy to,
for a father to swing too much into
judgment,
let's say.
And then of course mothers can play this
role to,
to swing too far into the domain of
judgment and to be too harsh and to the
degree that the father has his own path
ologies,
he's going to do that in perfectly.
You know,
he might be someone who's,
who's the father who devours his son
because he's jealous of the new
possibility,
that new potential that the struggle
for,
uh,
attention and love from the mother or
from the other children in the family.
There's all sorts of things that can go
terribly wrong.
So that's the farther as wise king.
And that's another symbol that's been
lost,
I would say to a massive degree in
modern universities because all we're
taught is to tear that down and to not
even notice that it manifests itself
everywhere.
Especially in the universities which are
like there is close to an ideal
environment as you could,
as human beings have ever been able to
create.
It's as simple as that and if you can't
be grateful for,
for the structure of the university with
all its imperfections,
then then you're completely blind to
this element of the archetypes
and that's the opposite of it.
That's the sun that devours the king,
that devours his own son.
That's a tyrant.
You know?
That's like the mother who too over
protective.
It's the male version of that and the
mother that's too over protective says,
I'll never let anything happen to you.
It's like,
well,
maybe you actually want to have
something happen to you.
You know,
it's a bit of an all inclusive
statement.
It's like,
no,
I'm going to make you strong so any
number of things can happen to you and
when you're,
when you need some care,
I'll be there.
But otherwise,
like out into the world with you,
that's the right attitude for the
father.
Like get bloody act together,
but I'm on your side.
It's because not because I want to
destroy you or demeaning you or push you
down in the dominance hierarchy,
but because I want the best,
didn't you to emerge and so are you need
standards.
It's like,
what are you doing wasting your life?
There's way more than that to you get
your act together and bring it out.
And that's a message that people really
want to hear if they have any sense at
all and generally they do want to hear
it.
So,
you know,
I was talking,
I've been talking to a lot of people
recently as,
as perhaps you know,
and what I was talking to one of the
leaders of the Conservatives this
morning and they're asking me about the
person who's asking me about bill see
16,
but more specifically about talking to
young people in.
Because the conservative leadership
struggle is going on right now.
I've been talking to a bunch of them and
I said,
well look,
one of the things you could do for young
people that no one's doing is to talk to
them about responsibility because
everyone talks to young people about
rights.
So like,
we need our rights.
It's like,
Oh God,
how many rights do you need?
You know,
really,
like you have more privileges than any
people who've ever lived anywhere.
Well,
it's so dull to hear that so dull.
It's so pathetic.
And,
and uh,
what would you call it?
It's so demeaning that you have to be
protected and have your rights.
It's like I said,
there's a huge marketplace for
responsibility.
That's what you want to talk to young
people about.
It's like get your act together and do
something worthwhile with your life.
For the first time,
my entire adult life,
the conservatives actually have
something to sell young people,
right?
They could sell them responsibility.
It's like,
well,
why?
Because that's where my life has meaning
with responsibility.
The more responsibility you take on,
the more meaning your life has and the,
the higher degree of responsibility that
you agreed voluntarily to try to bear,
the richer your life will be.
And no one's ever told that.
And it's the case,
you know,
it's like you have,
you have four kids say,
well,
that's plenty of responsibility.
You're going to have meaning.
It's going to be rough,
you know,
because it's complicated.
You have a complicated job and you try
to help the careers of the people well
around you.
Do you try to solve tough problems and
aimed suffering and do all of that.
It's like its weight,
its responsive stability,
but it's,
there's glory in it.
There's real glory in it.
There's deep meaning in it and,
and,
and young people are starving for that
because no one ever tells them that.
It's like you're way more than you
think,
man,
stand up.
Do something difficult.
Doing something difficult and heroic,
right?
Burst out of your borns.
So like,
that's a good message.
That's a necessary message because we
have to be more than we are because if
we,
if we aren't,
we're not going to survive.